So, you guys have to come on to this set and stand the institute set up and institute set
up you have the template reference right and template preferences we have this dynamic builder
report builder and the other one is the PDF template okay so PDF template okay so there
could be ID card there could be a lower certificate there could be one of our certificate admission
received okay it could be event it could be nodius certificate it could be admit card it could be
student's right so when you click then you have this option to add the multiple of the
templates okay is that okay so what i was saying is for example i have to create a fee receipt
right so what i will do is i'll select the fee receipt give it a name for example fee receipt
start okay then you have the count as well the
if you select the one the same then it will be a single receipt if you select two with horizontal
then two print only in horizontal and then you have the two as vertical vertical make over
then one just below the other right and then four is the four divide four
and then you have the courses courses is what like
class one class two
now there could be chances that a certificate can be different for
respective classes right the class one or two
let me go with the college one apart
so let's go with the school and right school of engineering school of computer applications
school of political science
right then you can do one thing
as you click
you can select the default template which are available at the back end right
you can get the preview as well
me
there could be changes in the alignment there could be changes in the you know
okay
you will give it to you right then you will select a particular template because the reason
is that the template you have selected here, for example, if you have selected a free receipt
and put the code of bona fide certificate in it, then when you will print the free receipt,
then there is a bona fide certificate.
for example, you have selected a free receipt and here you have to do one thing,
you have to give the template and after that you have to select the free receipt,
and in the case of free receipt, you have to keep the same template and put the name of the free receipt.
Now tell me one thing, what is this certificate, bona fide certificate?
Which template have you selected?
The one I have selected in the report, that is the free receipt.
As soon as I add it and print it,
now what I have done, I have made a free receipt template,
one template was already existing,
and I have created one template, that is the default template.
Now when I will go to the default template and go to the transaction list and print the free receipt of anyone,
then what do you think, what should be the print?
Will it be a free receipt or a bona fide certificate?
How much is the bona fide one?
It should be printed.
Which one should be printed?
Error message.
Okay, tell me more.
What I have done is, I have selected the template, your free receipt,
I have put the code, bona fide,
now what will be the print?
The template of bona fide will be printed.
Exactly, so bona fide will be printed.
So I have printed the free receipt from here,
what did it print?
It printed a bona fide certificate.
But notice one thing,
only in those variables,
the variables that we have given in the bona fide certificate,
if we have given its free heights,
if we have given its amount,
how much is collected,
then that will also be printed.
The bona fide certificate is also printed inside.
So always remember one thing,
on which particular trigger,
the particular template attached to you,
that will be printed.
Now no matter what code you put in it,
whatever code you put, it will be printed.
You think that I have created a free receipt,
then the receipt will be printed.
It is not like that.
You have to check the code.
Now I will show you one thing.
This was the old receipt.
Now what is in its preview?
This is the preview of the old receipt.
Now I will turn on the default,
and the new one that we made,
we will turn off the default.
Because the preview of this is our bona fide certificate.
And that is that.
Then coming on to the transaction list.
What else should be printed?
Transaction receipt.
Preview receipt.
Preview receipt, right?
Transaction fees, previous fees,
that will come.
Now simply my point to clear here,
that is that,
whatever template you select,
it will not matter.
That is only for that thing.
What is your trigger?
Now if you have written Govind in the code,
then Govind will be printed.
You have written Rinky, Kunal,
whatever you write,
it will be printed.
The reports that we are selecting,
these are for the triggers.
Because in the fee receipt,
there are two particular templates.
One is default,
if you default both,
then whatever you get, it will be printed.
But what we do,
it will depend on whether
you have made it separate for each class,
otherwise our single receipt is the clue.
We will delete it now.
And here whatever count is coming,
with this you will be able to clear it.
There are 8 report cards,
10 admit card templates,
1 employee card template,
1 event template, 1 admission form,
fee receipt, no-due certificate,
de-replication certificate, library receipt,
student ID card,
character certificate,
multiple certificates.
Sir, in the count,
how many types of templates are saved?
Yes, for example,
if I click on character certificate,
character certificates are 7 there,
and each one is separate for the school.
Sundarbeeth is separate for BHNT,
Sundarbeeth is separate for law,
Sundarbeeth is separate for engineering,
Sundarbeeth is separate for management,
we have given different names.
And we have also selected the same schools.
The one that needs to be printed,
I will show you there.
And we will default it.
Make sure whenever you make a template,
first you will check
what is your requirement.
According to that requirement,
if you feel that my existing template,
look, in most of the cases,
the template that comes by default,
like you select load template,
for example, I don't do admission transaction,
I click on character certificate.
As soon as I click on load,
the code that I have on the back end
will come up as it is.
In most of the cases,
you have to change the code a little bit.
I am not telling you the part
where you have to change the code.
But you have to change the code here.
For example, if they tell you
that your character certificate
should be printed in the upper case.
What is the character certificate
that you are writing?
This is the character certificate.
Apply styling to it.
Write the upper case directly from here.
Either write it directly,
then it will be printed in the upper case.
You don't have to do it like this.
As it was before,
you can apply styling to the div,
or you can apply styling to the span,
or you can apply styling to the x-transform.
Like this.
Then it will be printed in the upper case.
This is the basic thing.
I am not going too much into it.
The main thing is that
you should understand
from where the template is being printed
and what is the meaning of which variable.
For example,
I will give you a variable here.
DisplayData.EntityName
EntityName is what?
EntityName is the name of the institute.
Like SDJI, like RMPG College,
Pipe College.
This is the name of the entity.
Then you have the
DisplayData.EntityAddress
This is the address of the entity.
This is the state of the entity.
This is the country.
Then you have the pin code.
There are multiple variables over here.
For example,
the gender of the student as well.
The name of the student.
You can say
the father name of the student.
Do you understand, guys?
What do you want to say?
Yes, sir.
This is how you have to create a template.
By default, you have to select
in most of the cases.
Your report card is also your default.
In most of the schools,
if you don't have a high level school
or advanced school,
the default report card has to work.
They don't have the requirement
to do something like a high end.
But for some special schools,
you have to make changes.
So what I was saying is
this is the default toggle.
This is your default toggle
which you have to turn on and off.
If you don't know how to do it,
I have activated or inactivated this code.
You have created a template.
If you turn on the default as on,
that one will be printed.
If you turn it off,
the one before this will be printed.
And if there is no one existing,
then it will be printed
on the back end.
Yes, sir.
Sir, there was an issue.
When I was making it,
let me show you something on the screen.
Sir, let me show you something.
What was it?
Sir, here it is coming in this way.
Use default.
And I don't think
it is in the content shortage.
No.
But if you don't see
the load template here,
if you click on use default,
then something comes up.
Yes, yes.
It is possible that it is not in the load template.
It may be on the default button.
Your buttons were not coming.
What I was saying is
if your template is not in the system,
then it will be printed on the back end.
If it is in your system,
then it will be printed on the system.
The condition is
it should be defaulted on.
Am I clear?
Divya, Rinki, Kunal, Govind?
Yes, sir.
Okay.
So, this was basic.
In the template,
you have to add where you want to come.
What is the meaning of default?
If I have to make different classes for different classes,
then how can I make them?
Okay?
Sir.
Sir, when we will make it,
will the set default button be on?
Yes, the set default button is on.
Okay, sir.
Basically, in most of the cases,
if you get proper expression entity,
then in that case, all the side defaults are there.
But in some cases,
there are some ID cards,
for example, there are nine ID cards.
Right?
In the case of that ID card,
there are different ID cards of different schools.
So, you have to allow different defaults.
Okay?
Sir, tell me once, why do we do set default?
Once.
We do set default so that the code is printed.
That means we activate it.
Okay.
So that the template is active and inactive.
If you turn off the default,
it will become inactive.
If you turn it on, it will become active.
Okay, let's say there is a student ID card,
and I have set all the defaults on it,
like here.
And I have also ticked all the classes.
So, if I go and print
a student ID card,
let's say,
then what will be the print?
Then it will get the first.
Okay.
It will print the first in the series.
The code works like this, right?
If your condition is true in the code,
as soon as the condition is true,
your code is executed.
Okay.
So, this was the basic thing.
Remember one thing,
in the template, for example,
I have printed this for you.
Sometimes,
when you are working,
you don't get the variables.
Okay, you printed it,
the student's name was not printed,
for example, the category was not printed.
Right?
Now, there could be chances
that the variable you have set
will have some issue.
Okay?
So, what will you do?
You will have to inspect the page,
right click,
and then this inspect.
Is the screen showing up?
It is showing up.
So, once you click on the inspect,
then you have to come on to the console.
Okay? In console, you have the object.
Object is what brings your data.
Okay?
So, as soon as I opened the object,
all my variables came here.
Student's name, student's father's name,
student's mobile number,
student's age number, student's role number,
what is the section, what is the stream,
what is the total demand,
how much amount it has paid, right?
How much amount it has paid,
how much is in the words, right?
How much more amount it had to pay, right?
The name of the person who printed it.
Okay? Clear?
Yes.
Okay, now what I was saying is
that the student's category was not printed.
Okay, for example, you have to enter the category.
There is no such category.
Right? The category is coming here.
Okay?
Yes, sir.
Okay, now the category is coming here,
but it is not coming here.
It could be possible that the variable
that we have used there
is wrong.
For example, I have viewed the code here.
Well,
I will come on to the
student's role number, student's category.
Right? Okay, now look at one thing.
What variable did I use? Student's category.
But what is the real variable?
Category, sir.
Right? Clear?
Yes, sir.
There could be multiple
templates where the student's category
is written and the value is being passed
in the variable. But there are some
templates where the category is written.
For example, I will tell you
what happens sometimes. There is a student's name.
We have the student's name.
We have the student's father's name.
It is completely written. Student's father's name.
There are some templates where
instead of the student's father's name,
there is only the student's father's name.
So if you call the student's father's name there,
the value doesn't come in the variable.
Right?
For example, right now my category is wrong.
So what I will do is copy the category
from here and paste it.
Okay? DisplayData.
This will always be there.
It will always be there before the variable.
Okay? DisplayData is our array that
will call the data and bring it.
For this category,
DisplayData.student will call the value
for the reg number. Right?
For example, I have made changes.
I will edit this.
I don't have to edit it. I will reprint it.
Okay?
Right?
Did you understand how to take it out?
Okay?
Now there is one more thing.
You will not get
a simple object.
There will be no variable.
For example, you have to print the school's logo.
So DisplayData.logo will come.
You have to print the old new.
So you put the old new directly.
You have to print the session.
Because sometimes it comes like this.
The institute says to print the session
on our fee receipt.
So what we do is, I think the session will be based
on this.
So this is our session.
So what we will do is, like the category
below, we will make another div.
In that div, we will pass the session with the variable.
Okay?
Is that clear, guys?
Yes, sir.
And right now, I was directly talking
about every object.
But sometimes, your object is inside the array.
Okay?
Objects inside the array, like for columns,
position, fee head, installment,
and simply
for fee head groups.
Okay?
Yes, sir.
Okay.
Okay, guys?
There is a report card in nursery I think we have to click download, so this is the report
card of pre nursery.
And this is not available at the default code, this is a customized report card.
Data is dynamically calling, but the designing is customized.
So I am clearing, there are many schools who need such report cards, so you have to make it.
Data is coming, table is coming, everything is coming, and I have made this one.
So there is one institute that is RITU, I will show you that, I will show you the character
set.
I am understanding little by little what exactly I am trying to say, how data comes,
data is being displayed, okay.
Now the console that I showed you earlier was very easy to understand, but on a report card
the console is very complex.
There is an array and in that array you will have multiple of the variables.
In this you will also know which group is where, what is going on, what is the skill group,
what is inside it, what are the subjects, what is the assessment group, what is there
inside the assessment group, and then you will get the values.
but yes, there are few complex reports
rest is easy
so
I just showed you a character certificate
character was bona fide
now I will show you the template of the character certificate
which is simple
if you want something simple
this is the character certificate
this is default one
ok guys
why is it bona fide?
bona fide certificate
is used in something
I don't have much knowledge
it is used for legal work
in school
bona fide is used
to show that the student is
studying in this particular college or school
ok
as a proof
so this was our code
that was the default code
now I will show you the character certificate
please show the transfer certificate
see
this is also the character certificate
and this is also the character certificate
that will be the second template
no, that is not the second template
this is the design
custom
ok
this is the proper
custom design template
so this
this will also have to be made
ok
yes
this is fully coded
as it is pulled from the family
and the stamp is also coded
ok
this is also coded
yes, this is coded
yes, I understand
I think this is not coded
this is not coded
otherwise it will be selected
this could be
the
direct image or something
yes, that is the image
ok
if it was not an image
it would have been clear
that is the image
but yes, you can code it
because there is not much space
if you rotate it
it will look like a stamp
ok
so there are also custom templates
which you have to design
right, now if you want to
check the same values
then you will come here and open the console
sometimes what happens
I was telling you
certificate and institution
where is the character certificate
ok
now look at one thing
here the character certificate is increasing
but when we print here
it does not come on the full screen
ok
so this is why I say
whenever you make something
the preview is not final
you can check the design
you can check how it looks
you can check the code
for example, you started a div
or a section
now from this section
you have to remove the code
for example
I have removed the code
now if I preview it, it will not print
ok, it means
my one particular
is not closed
do you understand
it means that action will not be performed
oh yes, like
we used to throw errors
if you start a div
or a template
or something
after it comes finally
when you remove the code
or leave it
it will not be previewed
now you can check the code
is that ok guys
yes sir
ok
sir
once the transfer certificate
is not open
you said that
transfer certificate
no, not from here
from the student certificate
transfer certificate from which time
because every certificate
has a different name
in this, what is the name of the certificate
you have
mine is
Dukhand
certificate
ok, you can
rename the certificate
if you want
here is the TC certificate
here is the college living certificate
student ledger
here is the student ledger
ok, other things
are not signed
ok, so you can rename this certificate
your place
one minute, I will record
one minute